- C'est un grand hommet,t,t,t,t,
un pionnier du Québec inc.
Né à Montréal en 1921,
Jean de Grandpré va se hisser
à la tête de Bell Cs s s s s s s
prestigieux au pays.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS DE GRANDPRÉ
fils de Jean de Grandpré
- À l'époqueseseseseseseseseses,
c'était surtout anglophone.
Mais c'est quelqu'un qui était
très fier d'être francophone,
qui parlaipepepepepepepepepepepe
je retiens de mon père, c'est
qu'il a toujours dit :
"Si t'as une décision à prendre,
pren
décision c'est celle que
tu prendras jamais. Si elle est
bonne tant mieux, si tu te
trompes, reconnais ton erreur,
- Jean de Grandpré entredadadad,
puis devient le président
et chef de la direction de
l'entreprise sept ans plus tard.
en 1983, ce qui permettra
à Bell de devenir un géant
des télécommunications.
chef de la direction Bell Canada
- Quand je suis arrivé, c'était
uniquement une compagnie
parti, c'était une compagnie de
télécommunications et qui avait
une réputation internationale.
décroche des contrats sur les
cinq continents pour implanter
et moderniser des systèmes
notamment en Arabie saoudite.
- La compagnie a fait
des profits extraordinaires avec
Nous avons obtenu la réputation
internationale d'être
la meilleure compagniehohohohoh.
- Jean de Gr d d d dirige
également la filiale
une entreprise vouée
technologies en téléphonie, qui
a alors le vent dans les voiles.
la compagnie s'est effondrée,
alors évidemment vous êtes
triste à ce moment
- En 1984, il devient
le 15e chancelier
de l'Université McGill.s s s s n
dernier e,e,e,e, il se concentre
sur la philanthropie, notamment
un organsime qui offre
des séjours en plein air aux
- Le camp autiste aide les
enfants, mais il aide également
beaucoup les parents.
- Un homme généreux,
un homme de coeur, ça, ça va...
- Le président de la Fondation
partenaire, mais aussi un ami.
Jean dendprndprndprndpré venait
tout juste de financer
la construction deââââââââââââân
Park.
JEAN DUCHESNEAU, président
Fondation Papillon
ma vie. C'est un homme vrai,
un homme franc. Il ne disait
jamais le contraire de ce qu'il
pensait. On savait à
- Les gens aimaient travailler
av p p p parce que c'est
une personne très chaleureuse,
sympathique, qui écoutait
- Jean de Grandpré aura marqué